what the computation is where is it  occurring in the physics project in is  it occurring in the mind is it the  universe can you explain essentially all  it is is you have rules for how  something works and you just keep  following those rules so for example one  thing I've studied a lot are things  called cellular automata fancy name  simple idea just a line of black and  white cells and there's just a rule that  says if you have a black cell with a  white cell black cell for example then  you get a black salt the next step or  some all the different configurations it  tells you there's a rule it just tells  you what happens at the next step so  it's a really simple set of rules and  you're just applying those rules over  and over again and ultimately that's  what a practical computer does as well  it has rules that say how its CPU should  work and it's just applying those rules  over and over again